est ce que le futur vous intéresse moi
je me reconnaissais bien dans les propos
de woody allen quand il dit le futur
m'intéresse parce que c'est là que j'ai
envie de passer le reste de ma vie
bon je dois bien vous avouer que
certains matins quand j'entends la radio
j'ai eu envie de très modéré de me
projeter dans l'avenir
pourtant le monde de demain
il est là déjà en partie sous nos yeux
et ma conviction c'est que nous pouvons
prendre les commandes
beaucoup plus que nous l'imaginons et
c'est important d'en prendre conscience
parce que nos actions d'aujourd'hui
elle condamne où elles construisent les
futurs possibles
et pour illustrer cette conviction qui
vous raconter une histoire
imaginez une région cette région elle
est au carrefour de l'europe du nord
elle est au nord de la france elle est
l'une des plus jeunes et des plus
industrialisées aussi cette région c'est
c'est le nord-pas-de-calais et dans
cette région les habitants savent pour
l'avoir vécu que quand arrive la fin
d'une énergie qui a fait votre
développement
une partie de votre économie s'effondre
et avec quelle votre avenir et cette
région donc qui a été championne de la
première révolution industrielle qui a
souffert de la deuxième s'est donné pour
ambition d'être pionnière de la
troisième à ce stade il faut que je vous
demande quand même si vous vous souvenez
des révolutions industrielles vous
souvenez vocaux l'histoire bon mais
voulait rappeler quand même en deux mots
alors la première révolution
industrielle
c'est le charbon c'est le charbon c'est
la machine à vapeur et ça donne
naissance haussmann
r cela désenclave les campagnes la
deuxième c'est le pétrole c'est
l'électricité c'est les
télécommunications et ça donne naissance
à la civilisation de l'automobile à
l'étalement urbain
c'est le monde que nous connaissons
encore aujourd'hui et nous entrons dans
la troisième révolution industrielle qui
comme les deux autres est marquée par la
conjonction de nouvelles sources
d'énergie et de nouveaux moyens de
communication du côté des nouveaux
moyens de communication il ya la
révolution internet et celle là elle est
déjà largement commencé
de l'autre il y à une transition une
transition énergétique une transition
vers des énergies renouvelables qui va
s'accélérer qui va s'accélérer parce que
d'ici 2050 avec plus de 9 milliards
d'humains sur terre
les besoins en énergie vont être
multipliés par deux et c'est intenable
selon notre mode de développement actuel
c'est pourquoi partout dans le monde se
développent des initiatives qui visent à
économiser l'énergie et les matières
premières à mieux recycler à les
partager à développer des modes de
transport de transports moins gourmands
en énergie à développer les énergies
renouvelables à apprendre à les stocker
à mieux les distribuer et tout cela est
rendu possible par les nouvelles
technologies par les par le numérique
pensez à quel point votre téléphone est
devenu intelligent
demain ce sont les villes qui seront
intelligentes penser à quel point
internet vous permet d'échanger de
partager
vous réalisez le moment historique dans
lequel nous sommes
et cette révolution là c'est important
d'en prendre conscience parce que soit
on la subit soit on anticipe et c'est le
choix du nord pas de calais alors quand
le président de la chambre de commerce
de la région nord-pas-de-calais entend
parler de l'américain jeremy rifkin il a
eu l'idée de l'inviter faire une
conférence à lille et puis il a une
autre idée élan par le président la
région pourquoi ne pas demander à jeremy
rifkin de faire un plan d'action pour le
nord-pas de calais mais d'une manière un
peu original en nier en y conviant des
acteurs locaux en y conviant en y
associant le monde politique
le monde économique le monde
universitaire les associations les
syndicats
et c'est comme ça que pendant neuf mois
plus d'une centaine de personnes vont
travailler à distance en groupement
local avec des équipes internationales
de jeremy rifkin pour construire ce plan
troisième révolution industrielle en
nord-pas-de-calais
bien évidemment on s'est vite rendu
compte qu'il nous fallait trouver des
financements pour financer l'état de
projet qui allait naître
donc on s'est tourné du côté du
financement participatif dont on a
découvert la force vient dé plateforme
de crowdfunding et puis on a une autre
idée une idée toute simple donner la
possibilité aux habitants de faire en
sorte que leur épargne certes
développement de leur région
une banque coopérative a été séduit par
l'idée et alan lancé le livret d'epargne
troisième révolution industrielle
vous imaginez c'était la première fois
en france qu'un livret départ était
entièrement consacrée à une dynamique et
à une région bon ça a l'air simple que
je vous raconte comme ça mais ça n'a pas
été du tout des gens très très bien nous
ont dit qu'on n'y arriverait jamais et
il a fallu toute la détermination toute
la force de conviction d'une personne
avec laquelle je travaille pour y
arriver
et aujourd'hui se livrer il dépasse
toutes nos espérances
ça fait cinq mois qu'il est
r il y à déjà plus de 6 millions d'euros
qui ont été déposés le plus jeunes
épargnants s'appelle hugo il a cinq mois
et la plus âgée serré mandela 92 ans et
fait étonnant aussi plus de 30% des
personnes qui rouillent ouvert ce livre
elle n'habite pas dans le
nord-pas-de-calais et puis sur ce livre
je vais vous raconter une dernière chose
la première fois qu'on en a parlé à la
radio j'ai reçu tout de suite après un
appel d'une personne qui voulait
immédiatement ouvrir un livret alors je
lui ai dit écoutez ça va être très
simple dans quelques temps vous allez
dans un guichet de la banque que vous
allez sur internet et la personne m'a
dit qu'il était aveugle et je me
souviens que je me suis demandé si c'est
parce qu'il était aveugle qu'il était le
premier à voir les choses vraiment
différemment
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé depuis
il s'est passé qu'une dynamique s'est
mise en place
bien sûr nous ne sommes pas partis de
rien il y avait des pionniers il y avait
des tas de gens qui n'avaient pas
attendu qu'on travaille avec jeremy
rifkin pour entrer dans la troisième
révolution industrielle notamment parce
que le nord-pas-de-calais a un passé
industriel est donc une sensibilité
particulière aux problèmes écologiques
au premier rang des acteurs via les
universités les universités qui sont
très en avance qui travaille sur un plan
qu'elle soit publique ou privée
d'ailleurs sur un plan d'université zéro
carbone pour la région et puis qui
développe des preuves des projets des
projets étonnants comme celui qui
consiste à faire d'un campus
le laboratoire à taille réelle de la
ville de demain intelligente et durable
et puis il ya les bâtiments nous avons
dans le nord-pas-de-calais
par exemple le bâtiment des archives du
nord qui est un des premiers bâtiments à
énergie positive de france c'est à dire
un bâtiment qui produit sa propre
énergie et qui produit même plus
d'énergie qu'il n'en consomme et puis
nous avons des friches industrielles des
friches industrielles qui ont été pour
beaucoup
reconverti en bâtiment high tech nous
avons aussi des entreprises de très
grandes entreprises mais aussi des plus
petites qui sont leaders dans leur
domaine comme le leader européen du
recyclage des pneus ou le leader
européen de la fabrication de banque
pour voitures électriques
voilà et puis
regardez regardez l'église de loos en
gohelle qui est une ville de l'ancien
bassin minier
regardez son toit vous voyez cette
révolution
ça fait longtemps qu'on y croit alors ce
qui s'est passé ensuite c'est qu'on a vu
venir
on a vu des projets des dizaines des
centaines de projets venant de tous les
horizons dans les collectivités locales
par exemple il ya beaucoup d'innovations
et collectivités locales elles
construisent des éco quartiers où elle
rénove des anciens quartiers
elle innove aussi dans la gestion des
déchets roubaix par exemple expérimente
en ce moment le zéro déchet où elle
innove dans l'énergie à dunkerque la
chaleur de la plus grosse usine
sidérurgique sert à alimenter le réseau
de chauffage de la ville où une villa
côté a décidé de tourner le dos aux
énergies fossiles pour les se fournir
quand biogaz 100% naturelle lui aussi
issu de l'art et en régions il y à des
entreprises dans les entreprises ya des
projets lourds des projets innovants
comme le stockage de l'hydrogène comme
la construction de bâtiments
l'imprimante 3d comme les réseaux
intelligents
et puis il ya aussi ou l'allègement des
matériaux l'allègement des matériaux
c'est important parce que c'est comme ça
qu'on arrivera peut-être demain à
construire des voitures qui pourront
rouler à deux litres aux cent et puis il
y un fourmillement de petits projets par
exemple il ya une jeune entreprise qui
s'est créée qui avec des vélos
électriques ramasse toutes les huiles de
friture usagées des restaurants de l'île
pour les transformer en biocarburants il
y en a une autre qui a inventé des
éoliennes individuelles qu'elle pose sur
les immeubles et ses éoliennes sont
fabriqués avec des fibres de lin qui
elles aussi sont fabriqués en région et
des projets comme ça je pourrais vous en
raconter pendant des heures il y en a
300 autant de projets qui sont porteurs
d'idées nouvelles et créateurs d'emplois
et je pourrais vous parler aussi de
l'implication des jeunes des jeunes qui
dans leur école dans leur fac ou dans
leur lycée plans sur des projets
troisième révolution industrielle
les jeunes qui veulent être à leur
manière co créateur de leur job de leur
région et du monde de demain voilà nous
sommes en marche
nous sommes en marche vers une économie
plus créative plus responsable plus
économe en ressources plus collaborative
on ne fait que commencer
tout n'est pas facile mais c'est
stimulant
on apprend en marchant on ne prétend pas
être les seuls simplement on essaye de
le faire ensemble alors en conclusion
qu'est ce que je peux vous dire qu'est
ce que j'ai retenu de cette expérience
j'ai retenu trois choses la première
c'est que nous sommes sur la bonne route
c'est sur l'avenir c'est sur ce chemin
là qu'il est la deuxième c'est qu'on n'a
encore rien vu
des immenses bouleversements qui nous
attendent dans les années qui viennent
et la troisième c'est que nous pouvons
être moteur beaucoup plus que nous le
pensons nous pouvons prendre les rênes
de notre futur nous pouvons être moteur
nous pouvons révolutionner notre monde
de manière positive
plutôt que d'attendre comme souvent en
france que le changement vient
d'ailleurs qui viennent du haut du
sommet de l'état et de nous en
désespérer je crois que nous pouvons
être plus exigeant plus exigeants avec
les entreprises plus exigeants avec les
politiques plus exigeants avec
nous-mêmes mais en même temps plus
optimistes plus optimistes parce que
nous entrons dans un monde moins
verticale moins hiérarchiques plus
ouvert plus décentralisée qui nous
laisse plus d'initiatives et c'est ça
aussi la troisième révolution
industrielle
alors si vous me demandez ce que vous
pouvez faire vous pour agir je peux vous
proposer et je ne vais pas y résister
de venir vous installer dans leur
mosquée
vous serez bien venu jeter mais vous
pouvez aussi agir là où vous êtes dans
votre comportement citoyen dans la
manière dont vous consommez dans votre
participation à des projets parce qu'il
y en a forcément autour de vous alors
ouvrez les yeux
soyez curieux participer au plus près de
votre territoire à faire avancer les
idées et les actions qui change le monde
construisez dès aujourd'hui là où vous
êtes
le monde dans lequel vous avez
l'intention de passer le reste de votre
vie